hey guys Perry here at the Toronto
International Film Festival with another
review for you this one is for Barry
Jenkins moonlight follow up it's a Beale
Street can talk so James Baldwin
adaptation and it's got a big ensemble
in it but it mainly focuses on two
characters Tish and Fani they're played
by Kiki Lane and Steven James and they
are a young couple and they're living in
Harlem in the 1970s and their
relationship is just oozing with
devotion and love and it's beautiful and
it's sweet but they are ripped apart by
the fact that Fani is accused of rape
and even though he didn't commit the
crime he's thrown into prison right when
Tish finds out he's pregnant I mean
really just that synopsis right there is
going to give you a sense of how
devastating this full-feature can really
be and in this case berry Jenkins is
choice to cut the now of their situation
with the two of them separate with their
past where you get that full feeling of
love from their relationship it makes
the reality of the scenario or hurt even
more because you see the beauty of what
they had and the hope they have for the
future and then it's just taken away and
then there's this hopelessness to it too
no matter what the family does because
the family member Tisha's family in
particular they come together to try to
get Fani out and no matter what they do
it just doesn't feel like they're
actually gaining any ground like they
have any hope to overturn this ruling
and it's really heartbreaking and
devastating I would say the only thing
though that didn't work quite well for
me with the Beale Street cat talk is in
particular the pace after the first act
of the film and this thing has one
powerful first act there's a whole
ensemble scene at the very beginning
where Tisha's family is telling Fanny's
family about their their baby that's on
the way and it is just a scene filled
with powerhouse performances and it
really just kicks off the movie with so
much emotion and energy and and this
fiery feeling to it and you never really
get a scene that matches that and also
the pace slows quite a bit and I found
myself feeling a little disconnected
from some of the characters in
particularly Tish and it's a little
frustrating because the distance was
there but I was so drawn to them at the
same time so I found myself just sitting
there and and praying that Jenkins would
give me even more access than he already
did to her mind frame and what she's
feeling and he never really quite got
there the story is still incredibly
powerful and it is definitely one that
sticks with you long after the movie
ends but in the theater while I was
sitting there watching it I did feel
like I was at a distance and that was a
little disappointing to me but there are
so many elements that work really well
here I think these are two actors to
watch you've got I want to repeat their
names again Kiki Lane and Steven James
they are definitely going to be on the
map very soon it is another solid
directorial effort from Jenkins and
James laxed and cinematography here is
just absolutely astounding you've got
some great supporting performances
across the board also it's just one of
those situations where I think
everything is working so well and it
didn't quite come together as well as
you know especially when we're looking
at his last film moonlight where
everything came together exceptionally
well here that's not quite the case but
the film is still really powerful and
effective so I'm gonna go ahead and give
this one a B that is my review of if
Beale Street could talk I must remind
you guys don't forget to keep an eye on
Collider quick and also the main
Collider video YouTube channel because
we're gonna have more coverage from the
Toronto International Film Festival
coming your way real soon
[Music]